can you linger just briefly on
because you use this term a lot and it'd
be nice to try to
get a little more color to it which is
enteroception and exterior reception
what are we exactly talking about so
like what's included in each category
and how much overlap is there
interreception would be
uh an awareness of anything that's
within the confines
or on the surface of my skin that i'm
sensing so literally physiological
physiology like within the boundaries of
my skin
and probably touch to the skin as well
exteroception would be
perception of anything that's ex beyond
the reach of my skin
so that that bottle of water um
an ascent um a sound
although it and this can change
dramatically actually if you have
headphones in you tend to hear things in
your head if as opposed to a speaker in
the room
this is actually the basis of
ventriloquism so
there are beautiful experiments done by
greg reckon zone up at uc davis looking
at
how auditory and visual cues are matched
and you have an array of speakers
and you can this will become obvious as
i say it but
you know obviously the ventriloquist
doesn't throw their voice
what they do is they direct your vision
to a particular location and you think
the sound is coming from that location
and there are beautiful experiments that
greg and his colleagues have done where
they suddenly introduce an
auditory visual mismatch and it freaks
people out because you can actually make
it
seem from a perception standpoint as if
the sound arrived from the corner of the
room and hit you
like it physically and people will
recoil and so
sounds aren't getting thrown across the
room they're still coming from a
defined location an array of speakers
but this is the way the brain
creates these internal representations
and
again not to i don't want to go down a
rabbit hole but um
i think as much as you know i'm sure the
listeners
appreciate this but you know everything
in the brain is an abstraction
right i mean they're they're the sensory
apparati that are the eyes and ears and
nose and skin and
taste and all that are taking
information and with interoception
it's taking information from sensors
inside the body the enteric nervous
system for the gut
i've got sensory neurons that innervate
my liver
um etc taking all that
and the brain is
abstracting that in the same way that if
i took a picture of your face
and i hand it to you and i'd say that's
you you'd say yeah that's me
but if i were an abstract artist i'd be
doing a little bit more of what the
brain does
where if i took a pad and paper maybe i
could do this because i'm a terrible
artist
and i could just mix it up and i'd let's
say i would make your eyes like water
bottles but i'd flip them upside down
and i'd start assigning
fruits and objects to the different
features of your face and i showed you i
say lex that's you
say well that's not me and i'd say no
but that's my abstraction of you but
that's what the brain does
the space time relationship of the
neurons that fire that encode your face
has have no resemblance to your face
right
and i think people don't really i don't
know if people have fully internalized
that
but the day that i and i'm not trying to
fully internalize that
because it's weird to think about but
all neurons can do is fire
in space and in time different neurons
in different sequences
perhaps with different intensities it's
not clear the action potential is all or
none
although people neuroscientists don't
like to talk about that even though it's
been published in nature a couple times
the actual potential for a given neuron
doesn't always have the exact same
waveform
people it's in all the textbooks but you
can modify that waveform
well i mean there's a lot of fascinating
stuff with uh with neuroscience about
the fuzziness of all the
uh of the transfer of information from
neuron to neuron i mean
we certainly touch upon it every time we
at all try to think about the difference
between artificial neural networks and
biological neural networks but can we uh
maybe linger a little bit on this uh
on the circuitry that you're getting at
so
the brain is just a bunch of stuff
firing and it forms abstractions
that are fascinating and beautiful like
layers upon layers upon layers of
abstraction
and i think it uh just like when you're
programming you know on programming in
python
it's uh it's awe-inspiring to think that
underneath it all it ends up being zeros
and ones
and the computer doesn't know about no
stupid python or windows or
linux it it only knows about the zeros
and ones in the same way with the brain
is there something interesting to you
or fundamental to you about the
circuitry of the brain
that allows for the magic that's in our
mind to emerge
how much do we understand i mean maybe
even focusing on the vision system
is is there something specific about the
structure of the vision system the
circuitry of it
that uh allows for the complexity of the
vision system to emerge
or is it all just the complete chaotic
mess that we don't understand it's
definitely not
all a chaotic mess that we don't
understand if we're talking about vision
and that's not just because i'm a vision
scientist division let's take a vision
well because in
the beauty of the visual system the
reason david hubbell and torrance and
weasel on the nobel prize
was because they were brilliant and
forward thinking and adventurous and all
that good stuff
but the reason that the visual system is
such a great model for addressing these
kinds of questions and other systems are
hard
is we can control the stimuli we can
adjust spatial frequency
how finer the gradings are thick
gratings thin gratings we can
adjust temporal frequency how fast
things are moving we can
um use cone isolating stimuli we can use
there's so many things that you can do
in a controlled way whereas if we're
talking about cognitive encoding
like you know encoding the space of
concepts or something
you know i i've you know i like you
i if i may are am drawn to the the big
questions
in neuroscience but i confess
in part because of some good advice i
got early in my career
and in part because i'm um not
perhaps smart enough to go after the
really high level stuff
i also like to address things that are
tractable
and i want you know we need to we need
to address what we can
stand to make some ground on at a given
time today you can construct
brilliant controlled experiments just
to study to really literally answer
questions about yeah yeah i mean
i'm happy to have a talk about
consciousness but it's it's a scary
talk and i think most people don't want
to hear what i have to say which is you
know which is
uh we can save that for later perhaps
it's an interesting question of uh we
talk about psychedelics
we can talk about consciousness we can
talk about cognition
can experiments in neuroscience be
constructed
to shed any kind of light in these
questions so i mean
it's cool that vision i mean to me
vision is
probably one of the most beautiful
things about human beings also
from the ai side computer vision has
some
is some of the most exciting
applications of
neural networks is in computer vision
but it feels like that's a
that's a neighbor of cognition and
consciousness it's just that we maybe
haven't come up with experiments to
study those yet
you